c'est 100 morts dont une centaine de
civils et trois cent mille personnes
déplacées bilan d'une semaine
d'offensive militaire turque dans le
nord de la syrie des populations
entières privés de l'essentiel pour
survivre dame dit qu'elles n'avaient
plus d'eau depuis trois ans accusé de
tous bords d'avoir donné le feu vert à
cette offensive mise en difficulté par
un vote contre lui des républicains à la
chambre dans notre chambre envoyer son
vice président et son secrétaire d'état
en turquie pour tenter de réparer les
pots cassés après des heures de
négociations
mike pence en est ressorti satisfait
fier d'annoncer un accord de
cessez-le-feu touch and go prose à
l'origine tricherie soldats turcs dit
ils vont suspendre leurs opérations pour
une période de 120 heures pour permettre
aux forces kurdes de se retirer au moins
deux des gardes
d'un autre homme qui avait désespérément
besoin d'une bonne nouvelle dans ce
dossier parle d'une grande victoire d'un
grand jour pour les kurdes d'un grand
jour pour la civilisation
cet accord affirme-t-il permettra de
sauver des millions de vies il en a
profité pour remercier le président turc
erdogan qu'il a présenté comme un ami et
un sacré leader in the frenchman mais la
turquie un autre interprétation de
l'accord arabe et d'être à l'affût
tolkien meshuggah ankara il ne s'agit
pas de cessez-le-feu simplement d'une
pause pour permettre aux kurdes de
rendre leurs armes et de se retirer et
l' enthousiasme de la maison blanche est
loin d'être partagé par tous à
washington des last days being tried
pour le sénateur républicain mitt romney
cet accord est loin d'être une victoire
est une sorte de st
selon lui le fait que les états unis ont
abandonné un allié ajoute les insultes
au déshonneur ici jean françois bélanger
raid au canada washington